Do you know who is hitching a ride home with
you for the holidays?
Well they’re tiny and buggy and they look
like this: [Image of dust mite]
Hello everyone, Crystal here for DNews.
microscopic hitchhikers are everywhere.
We have millions of bacterial species crawling
all over us right now but in addition to germs
and bacteria several species of creepy crawlers
are taking advantage of our visits to grandma’s
house and skipping town themselves.
This may explain the findings of University
of Michigan researchers when they examined
the genetic connection between house dust
mite populations in the United States and
South Asia.
While genetic differences can still be detected
in both populations, there is enough similarity
to conclude that mite populations are indeed
linked genetically through migration across
continents.
This is important because house dust mites
thrive in the mattresses, sofas and carpets,
of even the cleanest homes, and they are known
to cause allergic reactions in more than 65
million people worldwide.
Gaining more information about genetic similarity
and diversity in the dust mite population,
especially when looking at variations in the
protein responsible for human allergic reactions,
will give scientists a better chance at addressing
how and why these allergies occur.
The scientists involved in this international
effort chose to study the geographical diversity
of the group 1 allergen gene because this
gene encodes for the most important allergy-causing
protein in house dust mites.
An inactive form of this protein is what is
used as part of the standard skin-prick test
for allergies.
Making the test more specific by including
the regionally appropriate genetic variant
of the inactivated protein could make the
allergy test more accurate and help more people
identify the cause of their allergy symptoms.
Interestingly, according to the authors of
the study, geographical variation in group
1 allergen proteins has not been extensively
studied (at least not in the U.S.).
The researchers examined genetic sequences
from American house dust mites (Dermatophagoides
farinae), and identified 14 mutations along
the length of the group 1 allergen gene.
Most of the mutations didn’t affect the
proteins’ structure or function, but the
unexpected result was the discovery that American
dust mites have bred with mites from South
Asia!
We know this because a rare mutation in the
allergen protein, previously only seen in
a single population of South Asian dust mites
popped up among the American population.
So the next time you sit down on an airplane
to travel to somewhere exotic, take a moment
to think about all the hitchhikers you’re
bringing with you, and the ways you might
unknowingly be contributing to genetic diversity
and advancing allergy science!
How do you feel about bugs sharing your seat
on the plane?
Subscribe to D News and let us know in the
comments down below!
You can also come find me on twitter at PolycrystalHD